Kayla Harrison signing with the UFC
fighting on UFC 300 against Holly Holm
so you guys know how big of Ronda was
Ronda was a bronze medal winner she's a
two-time Olympic gold medalist then
comes over what six years ago into MMA
she's a face of pfl for how long this is
why this fight's interesting to me she
had an interview probably six years ago
with Ariel and he goes you know what
about 135 she goes you would have to cut
off both my legs for me 135 we years ago
we had Kayla Harrison on food truck
Diaries she's a mini Brock Lesnar she's
Jack dude the cup for Kayla Harrison is
g to destroy her is she going to do it
absolutely the level that Holly hom has
been competing at is so much higher than
any other opponent she's ever fought and
she's going to be depleted at 135 Holly
Holm is world class Striker I think it's
by far her toughest competition so
there's so many storylines in this fight
which is why I love it